it looks like we're now live for the
next AMA ask me anything session this
one is for the month of September 2018
let me get a little bit more light over
here see if we can fix the lighting a
bit and shooting some video this morning
on Aristotle's politics book one so also
let me put the link to the and thanks
for the patreon support I should say
something about that as all of you know
my video work including this all the
public philosophy stuff that I do is
generally being underwritten by patreon
supporters so if you if you want to see
more of this sort of thing it's always a
good idea to chip in a little bit it
looks like we already have quite a few
questions lined up for me ahead of time
people got there beforehand this time so
that's good let me get the air we got a
live check so Carl bad asks when I give
a quick am a version core concept as to
what the hell is going on in the second
half of the Karma days and karma days
answers temperance as modesty than
discretion that's fine but when Socrates
and kriti astute auch about the science
that knows itself I'm entirely lost okay
so that's that's a good question yeah
they're trying to figure out what's so
frozen a which we translate as
temperance actually is that's one of the
key you know
cardinal virtues that Plato recognized
that the Stoics would recognize what
wood is temperance so this is an
operatic dialogue it's one of the early
ones scholars think where they never do
arrive at a satisfactory conclusion but
Socrates does lead us through a lot of
interesting possibilities and one of the
ways in which this gets discussed
is that maybe temperance would actually
be a kind of wisdom or knowledge of the
other things right and this is this is
something that Plato plays with but
never I would say never really
satisfactorily works out and and I think
it's important to keep in mind that when
Plato is doing these discussions of
knowledge sometimes he's going to lead
you down blind paths that are not going
to turn out to be the best way to
formulate things and so viewing
temperance or even viewing wisdom itself
as sort of the overarching knowledge of
knowledge or understanding of all the
other arts or sciences is not going to
be a very successful strategy so that is
that's what's going on there in a
nutshell and actually down the line
that's that's a dialogue I have a lot of
interest in it that's a dialogue I
should do some quick nuts up videos
about maybe put together like a mini
course in my my you know Gregory B
Sadler teachable Academy thing all right
now philosophy religion self ask could
you please elaborate on stoicism and
Plato's theory of forms
well the Stoics don't accept Plato's
theory of forms they Stoics are
materialists so that's that's kind of a
non-starter right there
they they they don't believe that there
is some sort of you know eternal you
know realm of the unchanging forms out
there
all right Zhanna Scarlett hi dr. Gregory
could you please put some emphasis to
what exactly Hegel is alluding to when
he talks about bacchanalian rebels in
the preface section of the phenomenology
me and my friend debated so so in the
bacchanalian rebel and he's using that
as a metaphor there right in the
bacchanalian rebel everybody is like
totally drunk and intoxicated and
they're they're kind of
losing sight of limits of where one
person ends and another person begins
they're probably also getting it on
quite frankly and dancing and doing all
sorts of other stuff as well and so that
that's the the illusion right and you
know for Hegel that's kind of nice right
you can have all this cool stuff going
on but Hegel is is all about
differentiation and showing how things
are connected to each other in a
conceptual way so a bacchanalian rebel
can't be the end of the story right
whereas for some philosophers it could
be that could be the thing that you
really aim at here's a more personal
question googly moogly where is your
favorite most awe-inspiring place you've
traveled to in your career so favorite
and inspiring I'd have to think about
the awe-inspiring that favorite you know
I've I haven't actually traveled that
much myself I've been to quite a few
places in Europe and I've been to parts
of Canada I've been to a good bit of the
United States although I've never
actually been west of Colorado so I'm
not all that well-traveled I will say
that one of my favorite places that I'd
like to go back to in terms of countries
is Portugal because I liked the the
weather and I wasn't in the south I was
I was like from Lisbon on up right into
the to the north I'd really like to go
back there sometime
lots of you know beautiful art a yellow
shawl over the place and houses are
really cool and great food you know
great great drink so that that was one
of my favourite places and then you know
all these wonderful museums and places
to go to to check things out ah
inspiring
that's a little bit tougher to say I'd
have to think about that one
maybe I'll get back to you on that one
all right Adam it is death for
philosophy to be intelligible it is it
necessary to be obscure for philosophy
what are thoughts a metaphorical
language and their interpretations I
don't think it's death for philosophy to
be intelligible and you know it depends
on what you're trying to do as a matter
of fact a lot of philosophy is trying to
make things intelligible isn't it
struggling and we we do we never do get
away from metaphor in language we're
always using metaphor to some degree and
so the people who are really big on
metaphor and who are cautioning and got
us against it's deforming effects or
things like that they're they're on
points about that but that's not the end
of the story it's not as if Matt if you
know we're always off base it's just
part of the way things work I mean just
think about that term off base right
that comes from comes from baseball I
think or or maybe it comes from
somewhere else but you know you you can
grasp the meaning of it we're not
totally at a loss when it when it comes
to that so is it necessary to be obscure
for philosophy no and and obscurity for
its own sake is just silly I'll give you
a different example from religion you
know I have all these very conservative
Catholic friends who you know would go
to Latin masses which you can find every
once in a while and they'd be like oh it
makes me feel like it's such a wonderful
ritual and be like you don't understand
Latin what the hell are you getting out
of it and they'd be like well it's
because I don't understand it makes it
feel so much more mysterious and I'd be
like boy you've really got things
backwards don't you the whole point is
to actually understand what the hell is
going on not not just to mystify
yourself or fill yourself with all sorts
of eerie
you know senses of how transcendental it
is you should figure out what the hell's
are actually being said
and I think philosophies like that -
there's you know Aristotle talks about
this in the nick of McCain ethics he
says that there's there's quite a few
people who see philosophers or other
people talking about big topics and
they're like wow that's really cool but
they don't understand anything that
they're talking about and they just
think that that's really neat and
they're they're sort of like left you
might say if we want to use a metaphor a
spatial metaphor they're left in the
antechamber and they're not going into
the place to see what is actually in
there
and see whether it's it's you know good
or or garbage all right here's another
one from googly-moogly do I agree that
Camus is like Nietzsche light no I would
say come who is dealing with his own
stuff and and he's definitely I mean
he's somebody who's read Nietzsche and
talks about Nietzsche at different
points he knows why he differs from
Nietzsche and you know if you want to
see cow Moos more developed work you
look at you know his is a later essays
and in particular at the the rebel and
there you know he's working with with
things that Nietzsche chose not to go
down you know in terms of his ideas atom
tight or what are your thoughts on
Hermeticism and other esoteric teachings
I you know I'm not an expert on that
sort of thing so I don't have anything
really to contribute in that sense it's
not you know from what I've read and
encountered of it it's not worth the
scarce time that I have to invest in in
learning more about it studying it
because it doesn't do much to illuminate
I don't get a lot of bang for my buck
timewise that sort of stuff and when I
want to know more about that I go to
some of my scholarly friends who
actually do spend a lot of time on that
I say hey what about this what about
that and they they fill me in on on it
so i it's not that's for me it's not
it's not anything that I see is worth my
time
I don't have enough time to actually get
the things done that I want to get done
or they commit to doing sometimes Luka
would you be willing to travel with a
transporter that scans and destroys your
body and then recreates an exact copy in
different location like Star Trek right
I guess for me the answer would be yes
and you could say yeah but what about
the fact that you're dying in the
transporter yeah but I mean we're dying
every day right and and being recreated
as a new being bit by bit by bit and if
that being really did I mean this is
assuming that transporter technology
could in fact transport the person
rather than just the bodily composition
let's say we are like thoroughgoing
materialists and we do believe that
consciousness can be totally
encapsulated in some physical matrix I
would I would do it sure I'd go over the
place then all right I'd save myself a
lot of travel time so that that's that's
good atom tight or your favorite poets I
don't read a lot of poetry
quite honestly especially I don't read a
lot of contemporary stuff
my favorite poet is rainer maria rilke
but i like him not just for his poetry
but for his prose right and and I don't
get a lot of time to read other poets I
do like epic poetry and dramatic poetry
but that's that's not what we typically
think of as poetry today here's a good
question from Lecco mirror I think how
it's pronounced you're recommending
reading original text over text books
secondary literature why can't we pack
the useful insights from ancient figures
in the textbook form while omitting
ancient obsolete parts yeah go ahead
I mean you don't know what you're
missing of course unless you mean the we
is us
scholars who are doing that for you and
that's what I do like in my my videos
and my own resources but I'm always
saying you don't you shouldn't deprive
yourself of the opportunity that
reading it for yourself I mean why be
satisfied with somebody at several
removes from the actual thinker text
particularly when you know if you want
to read Plato today he'll it's available
online everywhere you know nobody's
standing in your way you don't have to
be a member of a club or you know pay a
lot of money to go to a class or
something like that or go to some
monastery where the only copy of it is
kept you could download it on your phone
right what's to stop you from doing that
you don't even have to read it you can
actually have somebody read it to you by
going to LibriVox or if you want to pay
money for audible do that right so you
know the other part is you don't you
don't actually know what's ancient or
obsolete until you read the thing it's
sort of like you don't know whether it's
a good translation or not unless you can
read the original or you trust some some
other person who can and you know
there's also I think something else that
goes along with it you don't really know
a thinker until you read through their
corpus of works and you read into those
parts that you think are ancient or
obsolete and then you start to see maybe
some of them parts of them maybe and
then parts of them might really still be
very on point
but you don't really you don't really
grasp a thinker unless you read through
their works not just summaries of them
so I'm always directing people to to go
back to the primary texts ready and what
are some possible reasons for the return
of stoicism in modern times well one
reason is that it never actually went
away completely so we're not talking
about a return like it was completely
off the scene and then boom now it's
back there have always been some people
interested in and studying stoicism you
can find references you know throughout
sometimes they get things a bit wrong or
they emphasize the wrong part but you
know part of it is also the availability
of tax
the fact that you know as opposed to
like some other thinkers who like
Aristotle is worth reading right but is
there an easy introduction Aristotle no
you might read the categories and that
you know by the time you get to chapter
two you're like what the hell is this
crap right or you read the nikah mccain
ethics with politics or on the soul you
know with Epictetus you can read the
enchiridion or Seneca you can read some
of the letters or one of the
consolations marcus aurelius you can
read that that you know kind of
disorganized meditations and then you
can get it more into the the other stuff
and I think it's also you know we are in
a time when people are looking for
philosophies of life again Aristotelian
ism could be that but you have to if the
study a bit and understand a bit to make
Aristotelian ISM work stoicism is a
little bit easier to take right out of
the box you might say there's I mean
there's some concepts that are tricky
and and sometimes a bit misleading like
the whole what's in accordance with
nature what's not in accordance with
nature I'm working on a book about that
precisely because it's not as simple as
just well what's rational or you know
things like that
the way a lot of people want to you know
sort of dumb it down but you know it's
it's it's relatable and it does help
people with with things like emotional
management and goal-setting and
resilience and all these these things
that ordinary people can relate to or
people in the professions might benefit
from so I think that that's part of it
and then there's also this is part of
why I got involved with the modern stoic
movement in the first place there are
some people involved with it who really
have their proverbial crap together and
are doing great work in publicizing it
and popularizing it you know and that
includes the modern stoicism team so I
think that's a big part of it
Adam is asking for something that I
can't possibly supply you with the most
precise definition of love in your
opinion I think a lot of you know from
previous things I'm not a big definition
guy you know I don't try to supply
definitions
for most things and I'm sure not gonna
try to define love that that's a
certainly an analogical at best term
probably equivocal term
I mean it's somewhere in the range of
affection or effectivity right and it's
a positive one directed at people but
man there's a lot of different kinds of
things rolled into love so I'm not gonna
be able to give you one googly-moogly
what's your opinion on podcasts such as
the partially examined live philosophize
this or very bad Wizards well you know
I've been on the partially examined life
wants for an after-show never got asked
back so I don't know what's the deal is
with that and you know for my taste
there's there's a bit too much joking
around and and you know flying by the
seat of their pants on occasion but you
know it serves a purpose gets people
interested in philosophy never listen to
philosophize this if I unless I'm trying
to remember who does that one you know
I've been on podcast from time to time
but I don't have that much time for
listening to podcasts in part because
you know I'm I'm very busy and the free
time that I do have is generally spent
you know exercising in which case I'm
listening to metal or you know with my
wife and my kids and our pets or you
know the rare social occasions it gets
so I don't get a lot of time to listen
to podcast so I'm not a good I'm not a
good person to ask about that because I
don't I don't I'm more of a producer
than a consumer you might say I mean if
I was smart I'd be listening to them
just to like see you know what's what's
catching on and and what I might do a
thing on but right now I'm just too busy
all right
anonymous what is your view on free will
at free will doesn't exist should we
even bother with the legal system so two
very different questions I think we do
have free will I think that that free
will isn't what
a lot of people who talk about free will
make it out to be where it's like this
total you know liberty of indifference
you could do anything you want no I mean
we we exist within a causal matrix
it just happens at the causal matrix
it's a hell of a lot more complicated
than then you know sort of crude
determinist with like to make it out to
be or wish it to be because you got
always asked about these people who are
like hardcore determinists what what are
you getting out of this buddy
what what's your angle here why do you
get so worked up about it if people
don't have free will you know and say
well they're faded to do that so I do
think there's free will but we have to
give a much more complicated picture of
what it would be and it's often just a
tiny little sliver you know it's not
some massive thing and free will can be
hampered by many things but here's an
interesting question so a free will does
not exist should we even bother with the
legal system yeah of course because a
free will doesn't exist then it was
determined that the legal system would
come into being and you know just like
every other mechanism why not leave it
just as it is you know when I was
teaching in the prison some of you may
know my first six years of full-time
teaching was at Indiana State Prison and
I would teach this intro to philosophy
class and we would talk about free will
every single time there'd be some guy
who'd be like oh yeah determinism if
that's true then I shouldn't be in here
I shouldn't be getting punished because
I couldn't help you know doing what I
did and then the next guy sitting next
to him and say you dummy don't you
understand that if you can't you know
you couldn't have done anything
differently than that guard out there
couldn't have done anything differently
and the judge couldn't have done
anything differently you can't play
favorites if you're gonna be a
determinist you got to apply it across
the board you can't just say I get a
free pass from from it because
determinism and everybody else should
should choose to do things differently
as a result so you know I mean you can
say this about any other any other
system
might seem arbitrary unjust or you know
attributing too much to people now
that's not to say that we we can't like
look at the legal system and say hey
there's there's ways in which this could
be made much more humane or we should
allow leniency in this case because this
person you know had much less of an
opportunity to exercise free will than
this other person so you know I'm I'm
you know cool with that sort of thing
but the idea that oh well punishment
then is taken off the books because no
free will I I don't buy that at all and
either to people in prison you know most
of them another one from anonymous how
do we improve the K through 12 system in
the United States I've heard that the
school system used to teach Latin also
used to teach the classical works some
school systems did there there is no
school system in the United States there
is no there is no K through 12 system
there's an incredible patchwork and each
state has got its own different thing
each local school board does its own
thing
each school within there is doing its
own thing there are some federal
standards there are some state standards
but hey you know so much of it is local
I mean I think that if you want to try
to change things in K through 12 find a
local school and get involved with that
and get on a school board and you know
start studying educational theory some
of its garbage some of its really great
and there's a lot in between so that you
actually has some credibility when you
start talking about that you know if you
want to be able to say that there's a
case for teaching kids Latin that's a
hard sell so you got to be able to go in
and talk to people who don't share that
as an automatic perspective and make the
case to them but I would do it locally I
would not try to change it in a broad
sense because you're gonna get so bogged
down you know start once things work
locally and they start showing
improvement that's demand
among the students then that becomes a
possible model for other people so
that's what I would do
all right scrolling back up because it
jumped over a bunch of stuff let's see
Oh Mike Goodman has a very general
question how to decide between justice
or liberty why not both why not try to
reconcile them and then you know Liberty
in what sense liberty and justice both
equivocal terms you know as Aristotle
pointed out in the case of justices and
we can point out very easily in the case
of Liberty Liberty in what sense so once
you clarify that then I think you can
you can start to resolve that if I had
say do I want to pursue philosophy
academically even though I'm done with
an undergraduate degree in engineering
how to go about this it's a good
question I mean you can do another
degree if you want to do it academically
you got to find an academic institution
there's quite a few online and you can
look around for those they're gonna vary
considerably in quality some some online
stuff is basically just correspondence
courses with a few videos perhaps thrown
in many of which are pretty crappy some
are incredibly well put together and
sophisticated but if you're pursuing it
academically you're trying to get
another degree right if you're not doing
it academically but you want to do it
like along the lines of academic look
for open access courses and there's a
wide variety of stuff out there I offer
some in my teachable Academy you know
there's there's all sorts of other
platforms as well where you can find
good courses elbe thank you for putting
so much energy into this YouTube channel
your videos have helped me get through
several philosophy courses are much
better
understanding the material it means a
lot well I'm glad I'm glad that's the
case and yeah I had a guy actually some
of you may know from my social media who
stopped me on the street two days ago
as I was walking one of our dogs and
said alright you roll his window down
are you Greg Sadler and I was like yeah
so he got out and he's like oh you know
I watched your heidegger videos and then
it helped me through my corset and Emery
and he wanted to thank me and he didn't
interestingly he's the Marquette grad
student but didn't know that I'm
teaching at Marquette this semester so
yeah I mean there's a lot of things like
that and I'm glad that it that is
helpful I do have to figure out how to
get wider distribution of these videos
because it seems like a lot of people
are not because you know they're crowded
out by the glitzy five-minute you know
this and that channel stuff I got to
figure out a better way to get people to
to know about it so if you guys want to
post about the videos you know post a
video and say I found this really
helpful that might also help as well
Bryan what do you make of heidegger's
reading of Nietzsche do you think it's
faithful to him I know that Kaufman is
not a fan of it well I mean we could ask
the same thing about Kaufman's reading
of Nietzsche right nobody's reading of
Nietzsche is entirely faithful the
Nietzsche don't expect that it's more a
question of is it an interesting reading
can you learn from it where do you think
it's like off-base and where do you
think it's on track right same thing
with the looses reading of meetcha or
Stanley Rosen or whoever you want to
pick right as a matter of fact there's a
total digression but I used to you know
I was sort of a cowman reading guy when
I first got to grad school and there was
another guy there who had studied with
Stanley Rosen and he and I used to argue
back and forth about how to interpret
Nietzsche when I was going through it
still going through my Nietzsche phase
so you know what about heidegger's
reading of Nietzsche hey when you read
Heidegger on anybody you're getting
half that person in half hide right
which is not necessarily a bad thing I
mean if you wanted to just go to meet
you himself you can you can certainly do
that but you go to these great other
thinkers on this thinker so you can
learn something more about it something
that you might be missing in the text
that they're highlighting and I think
I'd agree you know I think he's on the
right track you know neol ism really is
one of the central problems the will to
power really is at the core of
Nietzsche's metaphysics I think he's
right about those those sorts of things
David what would be the stoic approach
on the fear of public speaking that's a
good question so and this is a very very
widespread fear and it's interesting
because you can also be afraid you can
be good in one genre and then be like
totally petrified going into another
genre like I know academics who can get
up in front of a class and lecture
without notes for an hour but you ask
him to give like a speech at a wedding
or something like that and they're just
petrified or I asked him to go on camera
and they can't do it they're getting
shakes and stuff so I mean there's more
to be said about this but I I would say
what what the Stoics would counsel is
looking at the object of your fear
thinking about what it is that you're
actually afraid of happening what it is
that could go wrong and then ask
yourself okay so why the hell does this
scare me so much you know let's say you
know take something that that is a very
common fear that people express when
they're talking about this what if I
can't remember what I what I want to say
well then you can't remember what you
want to say and people will either like
laugh at you and say oh look at that
jackass or they'll they'll be more
sympathetic and maybe some of them will
try to prompt you or you know but it
won't be the end of the world it's not
going to destroy you
if you screw up I mean I'll tell you
this as I'm editing
my videos into podcast lectures I
realized just how much I say um you know
right and a few other things so I say
that a lot too and that's just the way
it is you know if you listen to other
practice speakers they do that too I
just did it right there say um but you
can also think about well what's what's
really driving these these fears and
this is where you know stoicism might be
it might be useful to use an adjunct to
it like thinking about you know depth
psychology or other things as well why
why are you afraid of looking foolish
because you know when you were a kid and
you look foolish people would take it
out on you okay well then you could say
this isn't like that this isn't this
sort of situation or if they do is that
really going to damage who you are in
yourself and and you can do this sort of
incremental E and that can help you
through it and then of course you do
have to get up in front of a crowd and
public speak and probably have things
not go entirely according to plan not go
entirely in accordance with your wishes
but things still turn out okay and then
you you remind yourself of that one
thing you can do is actually have if you
if you have the opportunity for this
create a little thing that people can
can write on and ask them what they
thought of the speech and then you know
they can tell you well this is great
or this socked or whatever and that can
help you off so all right Baek ji Seon
just son what do you think of the
dialectic of enlightenment skra teak of
people seeing the world is an amorphous
mechanical mass that no longer sees
things as they truly are is it just
nonsense I don't really remember that -
it's been a while since I've read
dialectic of enlightenment that's
Horkheimer and Adorno x' book
people seeing the world as an amorphous
mechanical mass that no longer sees
things as they truly are so that's
ideologies
what do I think of their critique of
ideology it's on point in some parts and
it's probably off-base and others and
yet remember it was written anything
that's written that's ideology critique
is always gonna be by the time that
we're reading it probably a little bit
behind the times so that you know you
don't want to take it as sort of like
it's gospel truth or something like that
a meal what is your position on
epistemological justification I don't
have one actually you know but is there
a way around using axioms are we fated
to using unfounded axioms
foundationalism why do we have to think
about it in terms of axioms at all why
can't we think about it in terms of
networks well I can't wait you think
about it in other models are we are we
committed to like a very sort of you
know mechanical
blockwork kind of way of understanding
things I don't think so I don't think
that's the way we actually experience
the world or learn things but I mean if
you're stuck with that if you're gonna
take that way then then you are kind of
screwed right you're gonna either gonna
have axioms or then you're gonna have to
have some unfounded axioms right but
that's there's no reason why you have to
start out with with that sort of set of
assumptions so Roach can you elaborate a
little bit on the categorical imperative
so that that's an idea coming from Conte
right and by the way I'd recommend the
whole series of videos that I've got in
the contest
discussing the different formulations
from the groundwork of the categorical
imperative that might help out and I
actually I'm going to be bringing out a
class on khat sometime either this year
or next year so you might look for that
so the categorical imperative is this
sort of exception las' norm that's what
makes it categorical it's not
hypothetical
that Kant formulates three different
ways and the first two formulations are
the ones that we get the most mileage
out of those are framed in terms of
universalization
or in terms of you know treating people
as ends and you know there's like actual
formulas or these act always on the
maximum that you can will at the same
time to be a universal law of nature and
then you can go through sort of like a
decision process about how you would use
that the second one is act always so as
to treat humanity and yourself and
others never merely as a means but
always as an end and and you know again
you can go through like a whole sort of
checklist almost for how to do that but
it's you know it's a useful guide line
in in moral decision-making all right
with a Ling doll Sorenson where do you
position yourself in relation to
speculative realism I don't know okay I
don't actually position myself much
period I'm already kind of just stuck in
position and I don't read enough
speculative realism stuff then it have
much to say about it right there's like
how do you personally distinguish
between news and fake news that's a good
question
well certain certain news sources are
more likely to be fake news and we
probably need a typology of fake news
there's the stuff that's just utter
[ __ ] drivel right and then there's
like the stuff where it's kind of
plausible but they took things out of
context and twisted it their way and
left out important you know the bottles
and then there's the stuff where it's
like deliberate you know misinformation
that's being spread there's the stuff
that's like wishful thinking fake news
you know there's a lot of stuff and
there's plenty of information sources
where like you should head into those
information sources like thinking yeah
this is probably going to be mostly
[ __ ] here right and there's plenty
on the left and there's plenty on the
right so there's that I mean quite
frankly for all of his talk about fake
news you know I get the White House
briefings
the the little thing I you know I
subscribed you it so I find out what the
White House is saying about stuff every
day you should probably consider that
mostly fake news the spin on that is
incredible
right and and now that's not to say that
the Obama White House wasn't doing that
to or the you know W Bush White House
wasn't her the Clinton White House
wasn't but man this administration
really really spinning things and you
know there's a there's some news sources
one of the things you got to do is when
you read a news story you got to read it
through and then you you check to see
whether anybody else is reporting it and
what they're leaving out in the first
news story that modifies it right
because a lot of stuff that's reported
about about Trump or about his
administration is also [ __ ] and and
you've got to just compare sources some
sources are gonna be more reliable and
you figure that out over time and you
start to trust them but you don't trust
absolutely because they can always go
downhill so that's about as much as I
can say about how to do that
Hoess on how to study how to start
studying and practicing critical
thinking should we start with philosophy
logic or some nature in physics I would
start with the actual critical thinking
textbooks in that case they're gonna
teach you how to identify arguments when
they're being made with the parts of
them are how to identify at least some
of the the informal fallacies how to you
know make and break arguments that's a
good start and then you know often
they'll have other things that can lead
you to other thang places and and look
at the bibliography because that'll
refer you then to some sort of better
sources and there's like a whole
literature out there yeah you know you
can call critical thinking sort of like
what the pistil mala G is when you're
doing it in a in a way that's much more
close to the ground you know an academic
epistemology so you don't you don't
actually need to start studying nature
and physics you're never going to get
done with that for doing critical
thinking and and by the way I I'm a I'm
a huge booster when it comes to how we
define critical thing
and define in the very broad sense not
on the very like here's the one sentence
definition of what we call the APA
Delphi report there's other models of
critical thinking out there some of
which are complete [ __ ] some of
which are good in some respects but the
APA Delphi report the executive summary
which was put out years and years ago
just type it into Google and you should
be able to download it that tells you
what a lot of the key components of
critical thinking should look like and
it was put together by experts in the
field so you know not just people trying
to make a buck on talking about critical
thinking so Zen alight what are some
largely unknown philosophers or works
that you would recommend in any field
just things you feel weren't more
attention well you know if we're talking
about ancient philosophy
you should read Cicero and Plutarch a
lot of people that well their derivative
no there's there's some cool stuff going
on there and you can really learn a lot
of important stuff from reading those
two guys and then you know read other
people of course in that Canon there's a
lot of medievals who are overlooked as
well somebody else from a big fan of who
I was just you know just Thursday when I
was in my office one of my office mates
like he was pointing at this con
classics of political philosophy book he
says what do you what do you think about
this this is this good would you use
this for students so I said wanna know
let me take a look and see who he's got
in there and sure enough you know once
again know Mary Wollstonecraft no
vindication of the rights of women and I
was like well typical con you know great
stuff in here a lot of stuff I like to
teach but you know overlooks a major
feminist theorist who is is not a you
know sort of women are great men suck
sort of feminist but rather a we got to
put things on an equal footing and do
some cultural quick
and you know men and women both need to
get their acts together sort of sort of
feminists by the way somebody who you
know really practiced what she preached
as well she is somebody I'd read and as
I think a lot of you know the big fan of
legs chest off it doesn't get read very
much great existentialist thinker I
don't think that you know there's a lot
of lip service given to Hana Arendt but
I don't think a lot of people actually
read her stuff you know they read enough
to get a little little tagline like
banality of evil or you know they they
talk about how in our time you know the
origins of totalitarianism is a
best-seller it's a best-seller but I
doubt most people are actually reading
it because it's a tough book and it's
you know it's pretty dense but really
brilliant so you know those are those
are people who who I like there's you
know I we could probably come up with a
lot of others
Omar what do you think about attempting
to come up with your own philosophy
instead of interpreting the Great's
have all ideas been discussed to the
point that originality is impossible
well if you want to try to come up with
your own philosophy go ahead you know
then you know don't be surprised when
you put it out there and people are like
well this is just water down Russo or
you know Conte already said this you
know the question you want to ask is why
is it instead of interpreting the greats
what's wrong with interpreting the
greats are they just you know
placeholders who are getting in the way
of us you know doing our own thing or do
they you know put some stuff out there
that's worth digging into and
reinterpreting and figuring out you know
the core ideas what's attractive they're
why they're being taught year after year
after year if you're going to come up
with your own philosophy and it's going
to be worth anything it's generally
going to be after spending some time
studying with the greats and some of the
less well-known philosophers too
but if you want to try doing your own
thing go go right on ahead you know see
how it works out for you maybe maybe
it'll you know work out for you great
Mohammed are you a head galleon or what
no I'm not a gely and although I use a
lot of Hegel and nanami-chan although I
use a lot of Nietzsche and I'm not a
Kierkegaard II I know though I use a lot
of Kierkegaard and I'm an eclectic I'm
like Cicero I can say Who I gravitate to
the most but I'm perfectly willing to
draw upon other thinkers and approaches
when I find them useful and I try to
sort of you know work out a nice
synthesis of these four for myself and
for the clients and students that I work
with the greeter what do you think will
be left of philosophy when science
progresses further it already covers
physics and with brain research
improving it will surely have a big part
of the epistemology - that is the
biggest bit of wishful thinking that has
been said generation after generation
after generation the notion that somehow
science clears up issues rather than
especially when it comes to human beings
leading to more and more questions being
opened and more and more areas being
made uncertain just I mean history
doesn't bear that out and I know that
that there's a lot of people who love if
that was the case but that that just
isn't the case you know talk to
practicing scientists and and you know
the ones who are honest about what
they're doing not not ideologue and
they'll tell you that - I mean
neuroscience is just a mess you know the
assumptions that are made about what we
can do with like this thing that we had
you know the person in the the brain
scan and there's totally artificial
circumstances and then we did this very
artificial experiment that we can know
anything about epistemology or freewill
that's just a joke you know even even
most of social psychology is you know if
you think about what the experiments are
set up like and then the sweeping
conclusions it's just silly
to think that somehow we we rule Harriet
Sun philosophy but I mean again you know
see if that if that works for you
philosophy religion itself you're so
passionate about what you do what were
your first steps into the world of
philosophy what kept you going on and
never losing your passion well I can
answer the other one better you know
I've always been like interested in this
stuff and even though I've you know had
periods where I got sort of you know
uncertain about what what the hell the
point of all this was and even though I
you know personally struggle with the
depression I've always thought that it's
you know there's still something to be
gained out of studying philosophy right
and I found you know as I've mentioned
in a video but he did a long time ago I
found some philosophers able to help me
with that sort of thing my first steps
into the world of philosophy were
probably when I was younger but I didn't
know it as philosophy right
I just encountered ideas and either I
read about them and I thought they were
cool or I had teachers who brought them
up
III mentioned that my first actual
philosophy class in high school was
terrible if that was if that was all
philosophy was man I would not want to
do it at all because the teacher was dry
as hell
he used Martin Gardner's wives of a
philosophical Scrivener as the textbook
and I like Martin Gardner from from you
know his columns but that's a terrible
book or at least it was from from what I
remembered and he didn't encourage
discussion or really thinking through
through things so yeah can i lovey
have you considered doing basic language
tutorials geared towards some of the
classic philosophers I don't know what
basic language tutorials would be if you
mean something like going over basic
terms I've done that in tutorials with
people I you know I do individual
tutoring you might have in mind so
like videos writer courses but if you're
talking about like getting into the
level of the text and like teaching them
how to read Greek or something that's
not that's not something I'm suited for
I'm not a language teacher I can read it
but I'm not gonna be a good person to
teach somebody else louder yeah right
good Aaron is Deleuze worth reading yeah
he's worth reading I wouldn't read
everything that he wrote I you know I
enjoy reading his history of philosophy
things like his book on Nietzsche is
book on you know Lyme nets and I also
like that that you know selection essay
is critical and clinical and every once
in a while crack anti Atticus and read
around in it you know or a thousand
plateaus but I think I can't I really
didn't like to lose the ends personally
because they they usually just wanted to
talk about you know they throw delusion
terms out there and they they kind of
substitute that for actually thinking
about stuff and I mean it can be fun at
parties I can tell you that but but I
you know they don't play well with their
other thinkers that I'm interested in
Lucca have you read Derek Parfit what's
your opinion of his work I've only read
a little bit not enough to actually form
an opinion
he might you know he might be really
onto something fundamental but again the
people who I've encountered who are
really into Derek Parfit they never
really impressed me and so that's part
of this may be very silly on my part but
that's part of my way I judge who's
worth spending my time on you know I
think that reading and thinking about a
philosopher should probably have some
impact on you
you know clawful philosophy am I wrong
in seeing parallels between das mom and
I rents analysis of Eichmann I think of
this everyone doing it as das Mon and
practice no I don't think you're wrong I
think that you could draw a parallel
between there you could also draw
parallels between similar concepts and
Gabrielle more so the dots Mon think is
coming from Heidegger right that they is
what it's called and there's plenty of
people who were you know charting out
similar things Brian do you think
Nietzsche was able to develop any values
contrary to those he critiques if all
the highest values value themselves
wouldn't meet his new values and
evidently do the same so Nietzsche isn't
saying that every highest value
automatically devalues itself that's not
a claim he ever makes he's charting out
how the highest values that were
prevalent in Western society came to
devalue themselves in his view but that
doesn't mean that every highest value is
going to do so and it was Nietzsche able
to develop any values contrary to those
he critiques I would say Nietzsche was
able to endorse values contrary to those
he critiques but he's kind of all over
the map with that he's not not
completely consistent because he does
think that there's it's not you know
just Neel ism everywhere all right
there's pockets of things that can be
recovered Nate do you have any interest
in the work of Nicola small brush I did
back in graduate school but I haven't
read him since then quite honestly in
part I was very interested in Leibniz at
that time too and you know mob Rajesh
and live notes they're all sort of in
the same milieu he's an interesting guy
a lot of those Cartesians are pretty
cool there are a lot of fun and you know
he's somebody I wish I had the time to
get to right all right philosophy
religion stuff I see a book behind your
new stoicism mean I was tutoring a
student going through this this is
Lawrence Becker's new stoicism do I
recommend reading it I recommend reading
it if you want a very high level
academic treatment of what contemporary
stoicism could look like I do not
recommend it as an introductory text and
I think that this is a boy
by the way as mentioning that that
honnor rents are something going on
outside I was mentioning that Hana rents
origins of totalitarianism is one of
those books that a lot of people praise
and a lot of people buy and I think very
few people actually do read all the way
through I think in the meat you know the
modern stoic movement there's a lot of
people who give lip service to this but
looking at the things that they post in
social media or you know say there's no
way that they read this book because
this is really quite complex
you know Becker is doing high-level
theory but you know if you're into that
sort of thing it's really it's really a
cool work and I did in fact work through
the entire text with a client of mine
who's very interested in finis Toa sysm
week after week after week one hey
professor I hope you think about all the
lives you change through your videos
you're free knowledge is pure kindness
thank you for everything
question you teach your kids about
philosophy well that's very nice I I
mean I can't actually think about the
lives I've changed through my videos
because in some respect it's it's a bit
of a black box I I know you know I see
people saying thanks this really helped
me get through a class or you know I I
actually had a comment today or
somebody's like whenever I get depressed
like watch one of your videos and I
thought to myself man you must be bad
off if my videos can can help you out
because they don't help me out although
I do get enjoyment out of producing them
right but it's you know I don't really
know what the impact is quite frankly
I'm glad people benefit from it it's uh
it's rewarding doing it it's it's much
more intellectually and emotionally
rewarding than I'd say financially
rewarding particularly after YouTube
changed their algorithms but you know I
I'm glad that it that it helps people
but I don't know what the impact is now
do I teach my kids about philosophy
do but I don't do it in a formulaic way
so when it comes up I'll talk with them
about philosophical issues and I'll say
hey here's here's an idea that really
helped me understand this or you know
we'll discuss things especially my son
now has gotten quite interested in
certain certain issues certain questions
you know quite frankly looking back on
it some of those are things I was
interested in when I was his age too and
so yeah we do teach them about
philosophy we say we meeting both my
wife and myself but you know I don't
want to push it to too much because
that's how you get them to not want all
right Friedrich is it progress if we
bargain with ethics not sure what
bargaining with ethics would mean do you
mean like compromise our ethics or or we
use ethics as a bargaining tool would
that be progress progress you always
have to index progress to progress in
what progress is not a term that has a
meaning in and of itself it always has
to be indexed to something so I don't
know Ted Kaczynski hopefully not the
real Ted Kaczynski back to the metal
comment what do you think of Greta Van
Fleet I don't know what the metal
comment in here is did I miss something
in here
well anyway what do I think of Greta Van
Fleet I've only heard a little bit and I
don't know it sounded okay I mean I'm I
listen mostly to classic metal and bands
who are continuing doing that and the
present people say that they sound a lot
like Led Zeppelin I can see why that's
the case but and could he says they
suspect you can't stop it but please
stop talking of causality well
I couldn't stop it but I'm not going to
I don't know why the hell I should all
right Mandy could you do a one-off video
on the ancient Greek I don't I like I
love the vase of the killings and Ajax
playing dice in the agon everyone just
means contest so you know them playing
dice I suppose you could say as a type
of a goon but so it was wrestling and I
don't I don't know what I would do is a
video about that Shores found hands
strop an hour is better than Hegel yeah
it's certainly much open it Schopenhauer
thought there's some people out there
who believe that sorry I'm human are you
planning on making Schopenhauer content
yeah maybe down the line right now for
the time being I've got to make a lot of
core concept videos that I'm going to
use in my classes this semester so I
just finished up shooting to Aristotle
politics book one ones this morning and
then I've got to shoot some Cicero
content tonight and then I got to shoot
some Augustine this coming week and I've
got some Hobbes stuff I got a shoot
Wollstonecraft and all that so it's
gonna be a while before I get to show up
an hour now that said if you're really
really really hankering for something
and this goes for anything I do
commissioned videos where somebody can
actually pay me to like shoot videos
specifically on what they they want to
do so if you're interested in that sort
of thing you can email me about that
otherwise you got to kind of wait until
it happens right
H max do you view the world through
Hegel's dialects dialectics right in
part sometimes I think some of the
dialectics that he charts out are useful
for understanding what does in fact
happen in human behavior I think Hale
his discussions about nature and just
you know that stuff's not very usable
but his discussion about you know the
social world is quite often useful
heads say doctor sailor I always want to
know your opinions on mysticism its
conjunction with modern philosophy as
well as music I don't hold mysticism in
high regard you know there are a lot of
people back when I was in graduate
school or really into mystic things I
think sometimes in mysticism is just a
code word for I don't know what the hell
I'm talking about
or this feels cool genuine mysticism is
usually pretty disciplined and some of
that can be quite interesting but it
doesn't have much to do with modern
philosophy quite frankly the Mystics
usually are sort of been in the you know
off on the side most of modern
philosophy is pretty you know pretty
rational list or empiricist in what it's
doing so and music I'm not that
qualified you talk about music in
general I can talk about metal but that
that's really about it all right
I am now do I enjoy postmodern
literature what do I think of gravity's
rainbow and Thomas I'm not even sure how
his name's actually pronounced pension
is it all just nonsense so it's not all
just nonsense and I do like some
literature that gets talked about as
being postmodern I mean some people
think philip k dick is postmodern if he
is then i guess i like some postmodern
literature you know bor haze or you know
other people like that i don't like a
lot of high art literature most of it I
view as a waste of my time I you know I
was just reading something actually
preparing for the talk I'm giving on
Jean wolf by the way if you want that's
pretty postmodern stuff right gene
Wolfe's Earth of the book of the New Sun
you know shadow of the torture sort of
the lichter claw the conciliator I'm
forgetting what the other one is and
Woolf was talking in an interview about
fantasy and realistic fiction and the
interviewer was saying you know it seems
like in your fantasy you're able to get
at you know
the stuff that real people are concerned
with more than a lot of people in
realistic fiction and wolf says yeah you
know that in part because fantasies
actually closer to life than realistic
fiction I mean think about a lot of
realistic fiction it's it would usually
be about two college professors and he's
cheating on her with a student or
they're married to each other so she's
gonna find somebody to cheat on him with
angst abounds is the phrase that he has
and you know is this stuff that's really
relatable to us or do we read it and
then we're like Jesus what the hell am I
wasting my time on this for yeah my time
is valuable I'll give you an example of
one thing that is a postmodern work that
I really enjoyed and some someday I hope
to go back to and sort of chart out and
that's catch-22 you know I like to
catch-22
it's got a structure that doesn't make
sense in terms of the terms of the
timeline but that that's part of what
makes it interesting
but so much of the the stuff that's like
put up there is like high literature
that we should all participate in or
we're kind of Philistines I'm content to
be a Philistine quite frankly yeah and
so there's another question like that
I remember saying you don't like our
holy Savior Marcel Proust why not thanks
for the hard work because I don't want
to waste the time on his on his frigging
books you know I don't quite I don't
care the pub has his memories if I want
you know if I want to get like the
stream of consciousness stuff and you
know we're we're our memories and all
that yeah I'd rather get it in the form
of some good science fiction or some
good philosophy right
same thing for like reading James Joyce
view his stuff is just so self-indulgent
you know and it people who want to read
it and they love it
great that's fine they can do that it's
a free country right we can all read
whatever the hell we want but I don't
have to like stuff just because other
people think it's you know an important
part of the Canon you know all right
wholesome you have a critical thinking
logic and argumentation YouTube channel
that you haven't received any updates
for a long time are you still publishing
things related to these topics not right
now I actually have it in my patreon you
know like goals that if I reached a
sufficient level of support on patreon
I'll start producing new video content
in that critical thinking logic and
argumentation channel but unless I you
know here's the thing I'm a sort of I
don't I work for four academic
institutions but that's just like you
know per semester
I'm not full-time so if you want to see
more of one particular thing probably
you need to figure out how you want to
fund that right because I'm not getting
funded by the state like European
academics I'm not getting funded by
academic institutions to do that it's
you know the internet it's the people
out there who contribute to it and thank
God for the ones who do so you know once
I reach a sufficient level of support I
will start doing more critical thinking
it is because I'll be able to make the
time for that you know mo ed how can
artists better represent ideas of
philosophers is that even necessary for
creating a sensible culture or is it are
always arbitrary it's a good question
matter of fact I'm gonna I'm gonna
highlight that and put it in a little
document the reason I'm going to do that
is because this semester I am actually
teaching students who are art and design
students at the Milwaukee Institute of
Art and Design and I am teaching them a
philosophy of philosophies of human
nature course so I'm teaching them Plato
and Aristotle and Cicero and Augustine
and you know all the way up to ha our
rent well that's a great question
because I'm having them do that for
their final project so yeah all right
slow moan what would you define is the
major virtues
oh it's a good question do I accept the
sort of cardinal virtue wisdom justice
temperance courage thing that the Stoics
and plate nests and a lot of Christian
thinkers pick
on or a mime or aristotelian where I'm
like well not everything fits into those
not everything could be shoehorned
neatly I'm more Aristotelian quite
frankly and so by the way is Alistair
McIntyre you know he's willing to say
hey maybe we shouldn't try to cram them
all under four headings and I think
that's right
you know McIntyre in after virtue and we
send up moral inquiry and development he
says there's three virtues that are sort
of architectonic in that you have to
have them operative or you're not going
to be able to make much progress and
those are justice truthfulness which is
not exactly the same thing as just
honesty and courage and I think that's
right I think you're gonna have a hard
time functioning for long especially in
our society without some degree of
temperance as well but I think that you
know like Aristotle's treatments of the
virtues of Iran on finances you know
generosity or liberality and then
magnificence I think that needs to be
treated just you know separately and I
do think that it was a mistake to try to
roll anger and the proper management of
anger under temperance or under courage
which is what was often done so I think
that you know those are some of the big
ones from me I am them any books you
would recommend for somebody who wants
to start studying World War two and
fascism good question yeah
so you know origins of totalitarianism
definitely wicked vapors varieties of
fascism should read that I like Aronson
Nolte even though a lot of people bashed
him three varieties of fascism accion
France as mozu means Italy and Hitler's
not National Socialism there's a whole
bunch of good you know Studies on
fascism out there that have come out you
know in the last 20 years but those are
some of the classics I would also say if
you have the stomach for it get yourself
a copy
two of will shower looks there is the
one that everybody reads or at least
claims that they read because it's like
this thick the rise and fall of the
Third Reich that's good to read great
book a lot a lot of good source material
but you should also read his fall of the
French Third Republic because that's
another major part of the story and you
know it shows you why the democracies
were not able to satisfactorily resist
the the rise of fascism and Nazism we're
a little bit over time I'm gonna keep
going in the beginning was the splurge
you have much respect for David Foster
Wallace no but I don't have much
disrespect for him either I'd you know
again I don't read a hell a lot of
contemporary authors again part cuz I
don't time but and I'll also don't have
the inclination the few things I've read
have not made me say wow I can read more
this guy you know as an expert on
Blondell do you think his other works
will ever be translated into English
that's a great question there was at one
time track of putting together a blown
del translation project and like a lot
of academic things it never progressed
I'd like to if I have the time if I can
find the time I would like to translate
more of his stuff I did translate in my
you know work reason fulfilled by
revelation the 1930s for 1930s French
Christian philosophy debates I did
translate four of his contributions to
that debate but that's just a drop in
the bucket translation takes a lot of
time a lot of work it's something that's
best done in teams I think I'd like to
see his stuff translated but there's a
lot of other stuff too I'd love to see
translate it as well
dov says Wallace is a great author who
really confronted our bureaucratic world
yeah those Gabriel Marcel I mean I think
there's probably you can say that it a
lot of people the good man Tolstoy or
Dostoyevsky again why not both you know
I I like both of them I guess if I had
to pick one I would pick Dostoevsky but
you know they're both they're both worth
reading
Omar Alexander how can we distinguish
between morality and ethics you can
distinguish if you want to but it's a
waste of time everybody who makes a
distinction between morality and ethics
it winds up being a bit different than
everybody else's distinction and then
you have to explain the distinction and
you know they're both coming from the
same thing Athos and and Maurice right
they're they're both having to do with
this whole practical realm so I don't
bother making that distinction myself no
that's not to say I dismiss people who
do I mean Hegel himself makes a
distinction between it but you know I
don't I don't bother with that so here's
a really interesting one from I am now
is Camus syphilis just the night of
infinite resignation is there any
difference between them I mean I guess
you could say it's similar come whose
surface is not somebody who's embracing
the ethical right you would want
somebody somebody different than that
somebody who's closer to the tragic hero
symphysis is not a tragic hero he's a
he's a jerk who got condemned for you
know doing the wrong thing and now he's
got to figure out what the hell he's
gonna do with this eternal punishment so
yeah I think there's some difference
between them philosopher you said
elsewhere Socrates being sarcastic when
he says he knows only that he knows
nothing can you expand on that I think
he's serious but he's not being literal
he's referring to an attitude
I don't know all that means I mean if
he's not being literal what the hell is
he saying an attitude of not knowing I
don't know what that means but Socrates
I didn't say is being sarcastic in city
you might be being ironic
Socrates definitely knows all sorts of
things even in the dialogue the apology
just you got to read read it and you'll
see him asserting things that have to be
claims about knowledge you can't work
without any knowledge so you know you
have to kind of contextualize this I you
know I know that I don't know kind of
business is it something you can totally
globalize I don't think so
and then you know you look at the later
dialogues he gets people all the time to
admit that we know this we know this we
know this right Pedro Alexander would
you agree that all the actions
ultimately come from a selfish point of
view seeing one can deconstruct any
action into a self satisfactory outcome
I wouldn't even say you can do that I
mean you can you can interpret every
action as a self satisfactory outcome
and then there's some exceptions you
have to deal with but you certainly can
play that game if you want to but and
this is something moral theorists have
been pointing out you got to do so much
like totally you know skewing things in
order to make that plausible that at a
certain point most people are like come
on really and the fact that you can make
an argument about something doesn't mean
it's a good argument so what I agree all
actions ultimately come from a selfish
point of view no I think I think we have
a pluralism of reasons why we do things
you know Richard what's the best thing
we can take away from studying Hegel for
our lives today what good is he well
again I'd say particular dialectics
right and and and don't you know just
jump to the master-slave dialectic
because that's not the key for
understanding everything you know you
get into the reason and and spirit
section there's a lot of really cool
stuff in there that you can see he's
sort of playing itself out this is a
point
many times in the commentary videos you
can see it playing itself out today so
yeah let's see what's your opinion on
the attitude of which Arthur
Schopenhauer took towards the will you
mean like the interpretation that he has
of the will I think it's it's pretty
interesting it's it's well worth
checking out
do I think that everything is ultimately
at bottom you know will and then what it
makes of things no but you know I like
show open Howard quite a bit
Emile have you watched Jordan Peterson's
biblical series know when the hell would
I have the time to do that right no I
haven't I haven't done that all right
let me just the thing just scrolled up
again
venner what do you think about Stephen
Mullin news theory on morality u P UPB I
haven't watched Molyneux for years back
when I did I thought he was a hack and
basically just you know a guy who got in
early on the internet phase had a great
stick that appealed to a lot of people
that were attracted to his variety of
libertarianism and I haven't watched him
for a long time so I couldn't I couldn't
tell you much about him Christopher
Mulla must I've read some of the
pessimists like Chopin our leopardi and
I'm not even I'm not sure how it's
pronounced Chiron maybe Kieran but I was
wondering if you list off some good
optimistic thinkers within philosophy
depends on what you mean by optimist do
you mean like Pollyannish everything's
coming up roses or people that say that
we have good reason to hope but we might
have to work our asses off in order to
make those reasons effective I mean in
that case the Stoics are optimists right
probably most philosophers are optimists
in that sense so brewmaster does Hegel
being an inspiration of Marx's
some fascist governments and
philosophies expect except how you view
as writing snow I mean most of most of
the what they they made of Hegel and and
quite frankly Nietzsche's get you if you
want to make that sort of claim fascist
stuff comes more from Nietzsche than
from Hegel right I mean just just be
just be straight about that
it also comes more from all ghosts
comped you know and and Marxist I mean
did the Marxist really read Hegel
closely or carefully no you know so no
that doesn't work that way but I also
don't stop reading Nietzsche because
they they you know used him for that
sort of thing and I and I read people
for the sake of reading the people and I
try to see what's in their thought and
then you know if their thought was used
in an unfortunate way that's unfortunate
right I don't know then you say well
this is either a tendency within their
thought and they align themselves up
with it like when heidegger's blank
notebooks came out we saw that you know
Heidegger really was a Nazi right does
that invalidate being in time no but you
know when he starts talking about a
destiny or you know races the be on
guard right the good man thoughts about
psychedelics I mean people who are into
them
go ahead do them you know if you think
that you're getting something out of it
I think this thing about opening up like
the inner eye or the mind or something
through psychedelics I don't buy that
myself
if that is useful for that it's it's a
something that you net then have to like
follow up on by using actual mental
discipline of some sort
20:46 question on the relationship
between modern science and teleological
explanations and whether telly allow
teleology is needed for ethical
naturalism well you're going to need
teleological explanations to account for
human behavior aren't you and the more
that we look at animal behavior you know
you're gonna need some sort of limited
teleological explanation
for that doesn't mean that the
teleological explanations that people
gave are always great just sort of like
the Candide thing that you know what are
what are ears for well they make it
really convenient when we want to
balance our spectacles that sort of
nonsense is you know kind of in a bad
but yeah kill doggy are there funny
philosophy books I could recommend
Voltaire's Candide is one of the only
ones that made me laugh yeah Voltaire
has a whole bunch of other funny books
too I mean funny philosophy books
I mean Plato is kind of funny in some
places right
some of the stuff going out on the
dialogues especially like the symposium
depends on what your sense of humor is
right if it's a dry sense of humor then
you know there's funny stuff throughout
the history of philosophy I was actually
just reading seedy broads five types of
moral theories this morning and I didn't
realize it but he's a funny guy you know
some of the clips that he has you know
but but that's dry humor it's not not
like in-your-face sort of humor she had
white men did Vic and Stein really end
philosophy obviously not you know
Patrick Gallagher did you see the
Peterson Harris debates if so what do
you think about each thinker I have not
seen the debates I haven't had the time
but I don't I don't hold either in high
esteem so that's part of the reason why
I'm going to see the debates right you
know I think I think of them as people
who are interesting at this time and
they're gonna be flashes in the pan like
Herbert Spencer was in British
philosophy you know there's all these
people people are also also asking about
gee Jack I don't think people are gonna
be reading gee Jack you know 50 hundred
years from now except for people who are
like you know doing history of ideas so
alright
a little absurdity in my hands what are
your thoughts on existential isms
relevance at the time it came around as
a solid concept is relevance relative it
or was it needed as an effect of the
conflicts of the time well
existentialism didn't come about as one
like massive thing that all happened at
the same time you know there's there's
waves of it and was irrelevant at the
time yeah that's relevant now too
it's just not always the same parts of
it and it's not as if there's you know
one single agreement on what
existentialism is by the way anybody who
tries to tell you that that
existentialist position is this they're
full of crap
don't don't believe them they've just
read some sort or they read some Camus
or they read a textbook and they now
they think they know what existentialism
and all the existentialist think about
something the existentialist are kind of
all over the map on most topics so you
have to actually index it to who there
are there's a good one from ma I'll
answer a few more questions that I'm
have to take off in a bit do some
housework what philosophy courses would
you recommend for an economics major
trying to minor in philosophy that's a
good question
if they have a philosophy of economics
course definitely take that right I
think you want to look at the moral
philosophy courses right and you
probably also want to do the history of
philosophy courses that are available
because they give you you some of that
background in the history of ideas
economics comes out of philosophy I was
actually just tracking about that today
part of what's on the board there is way
Konomi Kay the art of household
management Aristotle's talking about
that in politics book one so they had
something worth worth thinking about in
the beginning was the splurge do you
considered failure when philosophers
can't live up to their own philosophy
for example show up and are pushing lady
down the stairs and living the life of
watch jugo moaning about suffering I
consider it an interesting biographical
detail but I don't
I don't think that it invalidates their
philosophical position
you know it's unless they they make it
you know absolutely central themselves
in which case it's kind of their own
their own fault right that said you know
I I kind of like I said I decide who's
worth the spending my time on by the
kind of people who endorse them so you
know that that has something for me
Stanton let's see here I scrolled up
again Stanton
Monnett on should I feel bad for liking
analytic philosophy more than
philosophies history no you don't to
feel bad about it it's good that you
recognize it right different people are
attracted to different things in
philosophy some people love the emphasis
on you know nice short you know reading
selections and they like the analytics
you know sort of focus on argumentation
and clarity and rigor
I don't think analytic philosophy is
actually all that clear a lot of the
time and you know if you if you talk
about stuff and somebody else has talked
about it before and did so in a very
intelligent way in the history of
philosophy and you are reinventing
wheels that's a problem but you know I
think that that there's different
personality types there's different ages
of life there's different support
systems you may go to a school where all
the professors are into analytic
philosophy nobody can really help you
out with history of ideas so I wouldn't
feel bad just you know realize that
that's gonna impose certain limitations
right certain certain problems let me
take three by four architectures have I
read castles genesis of being in time I
am NOT so sounds like an interesting
work but I don't read much secondary
literature quite frankly because I spend
too much time on primary literature so
you know there's only so much time left
sage master could Socrates have been
referring to the concept of Akasha
knowing emptiness itself in meditation
as a no thing instead of completely
nothing I highly doubt it you know that
would be an extraordinary thing if he
was there's really no evidence that
other other than pyro of Ellis that
there was any sort of influx of Indian
philosophy coming into Greek philosophy
until long long long after that so now I
would I would you know and this is sort
of a broader thing you can always find
parallels between things don't think
that that means there's a genetic
connection between them all right
Katrina baby do you consider yourself a
Christian apologist like he recognized
Kierkegaard was not a Christian
apologist so that's a non-starter right
there Kierkegaard actually said that
most Christians aren't Christians they
just think that they are and he was
trying to make Christianity more
difficult apologists do the opposite
thing that they're trying to make it
easier for everybody they're trying to
remove doubts and stuff like that am i
no that's that's not my my job you know
my job is is to read stuff thanks tough
talk about it if it happens to be
Christian thinkers that's that's great
but I'm not trying to I'm not an
evangelist I'm not trying to bring
anybody to one particular thing let's
see here a little absurdity in my hands
do you view Niall ISM itself as a
potentially toxic way of thinking or is
it the interpretation it depends on what
form of Neil ISM Niall ism is an
equivocal term as well it's meant
different things if you know if you're
meaning by it what Nietzsche meant by it
which i think is good good you know
index
it's it is a toxic way of thinking and
it is also an interpretation a constant
reinterpretation not just of a way of
thinking but a way of acting and valuing
and behaving but if your analyst man
life sucks you know there isn't any
meaning so alright let me see if I can
take one more thing and before I finish
up all right there's a good one to go
out on I'm gonna wait for Demetri to
finish writing this and then I'm gonna
take that one actually I'll start
reading it now well well he's writing it
I'm curious to see your reaction to this
post I am a 36 year old of the PhD in
philosophy I'm 450km debt currently
working to minimum-wage jobs in order to
stay alive I work alongside 18 year olds
and whenever they ask about my
background I just tell them I'm I've
been in prison for a long time which is
less embarrassing than admitting the
truth I am probably the and I'm waiting
to see the last part of that but I mean
I'll say one thing to begin a forty five
four hundred and fifty thousand in debt
for a philosophy degree I don't know how
the hell you do that even like you know
down over here at Marquette where you
can pay 50 grand a year for tuition and
room and board that would be nine years
right and and generally you're on some
sort of assistantship somewhere so that
that's an extraordinary amount of debt I
mean I know people who are like a
hundred grand in debt after their their
their graduate studies but I don't know
anybody who's that's that's sort of
medical school level
Dmitry's continuing perhaps in the world
my hundred my 1500 page biography of his
life has been we were missing something
in there we rejected several dozen times
no college will take me on since they
don't think whose role is relevant and
that other applicants are therefore
pushed in the head of the line I'm not
sure what was up with that but so this
doesn't seem like a coherent story but
the question is and we're along saying
18 year olds whenever they asked me
about my background I just tell them
I've been in prison for a long time
which is less embarrassing than
admitting the truth okay yeah that's
that's understandable
people do that publishing things doesn't
earn you any money or recognition
generally I mean academic publishing
doesn't do that and okay we just moved
to Louisiana there's a job opening at
the University decided to go all out in
order to get it that's great
ah so found out my application was
rejected well I don't know why why you
would move somewhere unless there's
actually a job it's not the way it works
in philosophy right you first you get
interviewed and then you do that so I
this this sounds actually like a made-up
story and if it's not then then you're
you're really in an unfortunate place
but there there's so many details about
this that don't fit what actually works
it happens in the academic world so yeah
but there are a lot of people who are
you know caught up in crappy
circumstances I'll tell you about a
colleague of mine who has dropped off
the face of the earth she you know got
stuck in this this thing where she would
teach like two years here in two years
there a year here you're always spending
time trying to apply for new jobs and
then you have to interview and you have
to move over and over again you can't
accumulate any wealth you
your network of friends every time that
you go that's a very hard life and
there's a lot of academics who are in
that situation and it kind of sucks but
you know those are the realities that
were currently faced with you know I I
worked for my my first six years and I'm
a maximum-security prison went to many
interviews the job that I was offered
was was at a four-year historically
black college struggling just to stay
open in the south and I went down there
and then you know went out back to New
York to live with my wife wound up
teaching part-time that's rough all over
the place right so yeah so somebody is
saying this is a stolen copy pasta from
4chan yeah it sounds like the sort of
thing it sounds like the sort of thing
that's written by somebody who has some
familiarity with academics but not that
much from from the inside but all right
so on that we're going to end we went a
little bit over time thanks for all the
questions and comments and again those
of you who want to make some sort of
contribution to what I'm doing you can
you can easily find the patreon page
it's just a patreon slash Sadler and
I'll see you guys either next month for
the AMA or we do have our dr. say other
philosophy dr. say other pop-ups coming
up later this month and I'll be talking
about ethics and there's some other
topics concerned with that as well so
hope all of you have a great evening
morning day wherever you happen to be